les chéris ce que je me suis dit voilà
c'est que on devait reprendre la danse
mais la danse ce sera plus jamais comme
avant
après ce confinement donc on va tous de
voir danser mine de rien avec un plexi
entre nous donc je vais faire des
couples j'aimerais qu'on enlève ce store
s'il vous plaît merci enlever ce soir
vas-y mon raymond et on va faire des
coupes et vous allez danser les uns
après les autres
face à face comme si vous étiez honteux
bois comme s'il était en boîte de nuit
avant que je lance le générique de ces
que du kif
on y va premier couple maxime gainey
valérie benaïm allez-y faites vous
plaisir
regardez elle envoyait musique merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci c'est bon c'est le
catastrophe
merci allez vas-y raymond et et kenny va
tirer merkel il m'a dit ah ouais pas mal
pas mal
ouais c'est pas mal bravo
c'est bien pourquoi il marque toujours
pas aller chez les ja pas la peine de
les céder merci un jeu super super ça
vient de le mettre ton directeur de
rougier hanifi merci allégeant bichonner
jean michel isabelle vasile à côté voilà
c'est la tristesse